to our
uh thursday informatics conference of
the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology at ohsu
which has
uh continued uh as it used to in the big
theater and now virtually and maybe
someday we'll be
back to the big theater in the not too
distant future
it gives me great great pleasure today
to um introduce our speaker
dr mohammed adibuzaman or as he prefers
to go by adib
adeeb is one of our newest faculty
members in the department
he's been here
a little under a year and um
he um has an another uh in addition to
being a faculty member has an important
role at ohsu
as co-director of the biomedical
informatics program of oak tree the
oregon clinical and translational
research institute so he splits his time
or really actually spends most of his
time
leading
the oak tree informatics program
but he also is a member of our faculty
and um
one of the reasons why i wanted him to
speak is so other faculty and students
can get to know his work a little better
and look for
opportunities for collaboration
mentoring and so forth
so
in addition to his oak tree co-director
role
he is an assistant professor in the
division of bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine of the
department
he um
has a
phd
from marquette university
in computational sciences also has a
master's degree
originally got his bachelor's degree at
the bangladesh university of engineering
and technology in computer science and
engineering he spent a number of years
at purdue university and then we
recruited him to
ohsu
and that's where he is now so he's going
to talk today on the topic of
informatics systems and methods for
evidence generation in medicine
and
um as always we will record this it will
be posted to our youtube channel
um it will um
and he will give his talk uh people are
free to uh post questions or comments in
the chat uh he'll leave some time for
discussion at the end of his talk as
always people are encouraged to keep
their cameras on although it is the
lunch hour and
some people may turn their cameras off
while they eat their lunch
so um uh go ahead adeep
thanks so much bill uh can you hear me i
see my slides yes we hear you fine
awesome
so thanks for the kind introduction bill
uh this is a little bit awkward to give
presentation uh in zoom or webex
but i'm trying to getting used to it
so for today i will talk uh mostly about
my journey from a computer science
background in healthcare or medicine
and uh so i have like four different
components in general the first half is
about my background and some why i work
in healthcare
and then i will talk about two broad
areas regarding informatics system and
some of the mathematical work that i
work on
and then finally i'll also talk about a
little bit about the informatics uh
work uh that we are doing at oak tree uh
that i call it with dr sharon mcwinney
so starting with my um
journey into informatics and
epidemiology or clinical epidemiology
so this is uh bill already did a very
good summary of my background
but as bill mentioned i worked
uh my undergrad degree was in computer
science and engineering and then i had a
phd in computational science
uh but after my undergrad i worked as a
software engineer for a few years
and then um
i worked in singapore as a research
assistant for national university of
singapore for a few months and then came
to the u.s was working on a phd at
market university on computational
science
but during my phd i got a chance to work
at the u.s fda
for a few years as an oris fellow
which stands for the oak creek institute
of science and engineering fellow
and that really actually uh had a deep
impact on my trajectory of my career so
i'll talk about that on the first half
and uh after that experience i worked at
purdue university registry center for
healthcare engineering
uh for a few years actually more than
six years
uh it's it's not a very small amount of
time
but purdue is a very engineering and
computer science and statistic
statistics focused university
but they have a center for healthcare
engineering and i was working there and
building these informatics systems and
working with uh collaborators across the
campus on
developing ai solutions uh in in
medicine
and then uh i was recruited at ohsu uh
like october
uh 2021 so i've been here for around
almost uh three and a half months now
and as uh
bill mentioned i have two different hats
one is the oak tree co-director
of informatics and the assistant
professor of demise
so uh
i will start with um
some of the projects that i worked at
the fda
and uh then highlight how i got into
these two areas of research that i'm
working on on the informatic systems and
methods
so the first project i worked at the fda
was
developing a
algorithmic system to predict hemorrhage
or to detect hemorrhage or predict acute
hypotensive episode from blood pressure
data
so for that particular study
we were given
animal study data
so these animals were anesthetized and
they were taking bloods from these
animals
and then
they were monitored for all of their
vital signs at a very high frequency
so they were collecting data at 1000
samples per second
and looking at heart rate blood pressure
pulse oximetry uh pretty much everything
you can think of
so my project was around can we
look into this blood pressure data
and can predict
uh
acute hypotensive episode or detect
hemorrhage early enough so that
we can make interventions and that is
particularly important
for human health because
in in a mass casualty situation or
traumatic injury cases
uh it's very difficult to identify uh
acute uh internal hemorrhage or blood
loss
and if you can do but there are some
treatments and you can intervene early
so this was a u.s funded u.s army funded
project at the fda
so what we did we looked into the blood
pressure data as you can see in the
first
in the in the in this figure
the x-axis represents the time and the
y-axis represents different vital signs
and the
zero red vertical line indicates the
starting point of the hemorrhage
and as soon as the hemorrhage starts
the two things generally happen one is
the systolic blood pressure decrease
but to compensate the loss of blood
volume and
maintain the tissue partition the body
reacts in a way so that uh it actually
increases the heart rate
uh to compensate the blood loss
and that's what you see on the left hand
side figure the heart rate is also
increasing
but at some point uh the the body cannot
take it anymore and it just collapses
and and the peak actually dies in this
case
uh so we were looking at this blood
pressure data and we used a markov chain
uh simulation model
so basically what we did was
we divided the blood pressure into
different states
and
tried to identify how
these
state uh changes the transition to
different stage changes in terms of the
blood pressure
as the hemorrhage progresses
so with that
um
in this is just a simple
example we had three different states in
this case and we computed
how each of these samples from one range
moves to the another range and it is a
moving window and over a 20 second
window
do we see any change in system dynamics
in terms of the markov chain that would
give a different pattern as the progress
as the hemorrhage progresses
and we found that
uh the second largest eigenvalue of the
markov chain with a specific parameter
mixing rate
we call that mixing rate
gives a pretty good indication of
progressing progressive hemorrhage
and we could detect hemorrhage pretty
early
and this is the figure that you see here
at the bottom mixing rate
and that shows that change pretty
quickly like within a few minutes we
could identify that there is a change
from all the different animals so this
is one example but we did a statistical
test
with nine different animals and and this
this works pretty much with every every
case
but while working on this project and
i'm referring to this project because
this was one of the motivating projects
that i worked on but while working on
this project as a phd student at the fda
i spent almost two years during my phd
time
to set up these high frequency thousand
samples per second data
into a supercomputer
and have all this software installed
and run this simulation where we are
generating like thousands of images for
pattern recognition and validating those
with the statistical tests
and i thought like
um
it was uh
they were taking a
catheter they put some catheter and then
they're just taking the blood from from
the animals
uh if if that answers to your question
so
uh as i was saying that it i felt like i
uh spent a ton of time
on the system development rather than on
the actual algorithmic question so one
thing i wanted to do was build a
different or better system where uh
developing those high performance
environment for a phd student or
researcher should be pretty simple and
they should not spend a huge amount of
time
on how to set up the data for analysis
uh
i also so that is one area that i focus
later on in my work at purdue
and then i also worked on another
project at the fda
and this was on evolution of machine
learning algorithm
for risk benefit analysis
and
this also led to
one other areas that i worked on later
in my career which is the causal
inference techniques
so this particular study focused on on
one specific algorithm development
for prediction using different
algorithms like decision tree support
vector machine neural network and many
more
so
we looked into
one uh research question which is
can we create how do we predict uh
medical emergency team activation
criteria
uh which is a criteria of uh three vital
signs
falling into different categories that
would indicate
a rapid decline in
health status so
uh
if the heart rate falls below heart rate
increases or falls below certain range
this criteria is triggered and an immune
system actually goes to resuscitate or
help the patient same with systolic
blood pressure
or oxygen saturation so in this case uh
this medical emergency
activation criteria was triggered
because if you look at the target window
and this was actually
to the best of my recollection was a
contest or a challenge
so
here the first window x axis
between 0 to 60 this is the observation
window
and then the idea is can you predict by
looking at this observation window data
just these three vital signs and we do
not have
access to this gap window which is 60
minutes after the observation window
but we'll us only have
the data 10 minutes after the 60 minutes
of the gap window and within that 10
minutes we have to predict whether
there will be a met activation criteria
triggered or not
so in this case the oxygen saturation
falls below 85
saturation level and that was one of the
criteria for main activation so this was
a true positive event
and we are trained this algorithm with
hundreds of patients data
from mimic database
and then
we developed these machine learning
algorithms and as you can see
we have reported
two different algorithms decision tree
and support vector machine
and we used different training size
uh with different cross validation
so
the first four is uh like we have a
training size of 500 patients
uh but we have four different splits and
then we also tested with a training size
with 1000 samples with two different
splits and one uh
case of 1500 samples for training and
another case of 200 samples per training
that's what you see on the x-axis on the
box plots
and then we reported the sensitivity and
specificity and all other machine
learning algorithms matrices for those
different training sizes and random
splits
uh and we found that there is a pretty
wide variety
for those sensitivity and specificity
with the same data but with different
random splits and different random
um
different training sizes
so one question we were very interested
in was
how do we
explain this variability of machine
learning in a
transparent and explainable way
and i had been thinking about this
during my phd
and then i focused one other research
area which is the causal inference using
graphical models
and
that also is a theoretical work that i
explored at peru university
so
going forward from
the takeaway message from my experience
at fda with these two projects where i
wanted to explore in these two areas
like how do we
develop informatics systems for
easier exploration and visualization and
computational systems that would
expedite the translation piece and also
once these algorithms are developed how
do we explain this and understand this
in a transparent way for risk benefit
analysis and communicate that with the
clinical
experts so uh as i said so this is the
big research uh agenda that i was
working on uh going forward since i
started purdue so we have all these
different types of data ehr genomics
imaging wearables
and most of these data are big data but
they are called biased data or
observational data
because of confounding and other other
reasons
selection bias as well as other reasons
but at the same time historically we
rely in medicine on randomized control
trial data which are considered
experimental data or good data
and traditionally uh the regulatory
bodies like fda rely on that kind of
data for evidence generation in medicine
so
the
question is how do we actually combine
these two different types of data
both
technologically informative system wise
and methodologically
to complement randomized control trial
to expedite
um
uh randomized control trials or even in
some cases do virtual randomized control
trial uh with all the reform dataset so
these are the two broad areas that i had
pursued
and i'll talk about these two areas in
the next few slides
so the first area is the big data system
for reproducible research
and
the idea here is that
if we want to develop a cloud system or
hpc system
that would integrate all these different
types of data like genomics laboratory
prescriptions electronic health records
variables
administrative data like insurance
claims and we have many different
stakeholders like researchers industry
partners
patients physicians and government uh
research agencies and policy makers as
well
so for that kind of environment uh if we
think about this is a very large data
system
what type of features or characteristics
that we want in that system
and we listed a few here reproducibility
shareability
data governance
irb and data use agreement
protections uh privacy of individual
patients
security data aggregation data
management audit trail of different data
usage uh computational system management
uh like hardware
uh usage
research applications and uh for
different um
researchers that are very different from
one another and sustainability and
maintenance of that kind of system
so
i've been working in this area for a
while and this is a huge
area and there are many industries and
many companies that actually have made
significant
inroads in in this area
but uh in my humble opinion i think this
is still
in its infancy about what can or needs
to be developed for a
large-scale data aggregation platform
in the cloud or in the on-premise system
so
to develop that kind of system uh on the
right hand side the figure that we see
here
uh i broadly specify this as four
different types of layers
the first is the infrastructure layer
which is the computing storage
networking security and those
traditional
big data or data center management type
of
infrastructure and then the second
module is the data preparation and load
which is uh includes the identification
data standardization and each of these
areas are actually a
large area that a lot of people have
been working on
in different ways as an example
standardization for electronic health
record is a huge area
but uh this needs to be integrated with
other sources of data and standard
methods and tools and protocols needs to
be developed
for other types of data as well
the third module i refer to as the
analytics environment which is
we want to support
the researchers with an open and
modularized architecture so that we can
support
different programming languages
reproducibility data provenance
shareability of code where we can share
the code but we can test the hypothesis
with a different data set and as the
data is evolving and changing
how do we keep track of versions of data
and reproduce previous results uh for a
better concept
consensus
on on
research research projects or research
results
access management i have this as a
privacy uh
preserving uh layer and in that
infrastructure system
um and irb data use agreement audit
trail dear identification privacy
privacy preserving record linkage
all of these are part of that
layer of systems
and finally the applications uh are are
the clinical applications or
the ai applications or even uh research
applications so there could be uh
clinical decision making as well as uh
publication focused applications or ai
model development so that should be in
the final layer it could be real-time or
offline applications
so to as
i said this is a huge area and uh what i
started was
uh
as a prototype environment development i
worked on a project for module 3 which
is analyze develop an analytics
environment
in an open architecture for
reproducibility and provenance
with programming language agnostic
interface
so this is what i worked on on that area
um so we developed a open source
uh software stack
with hadoop kubernetes jupiter notebook
and different open source technologies
to integrate
electronic health records
data or claims data insurance claims so
if you look at the hadoop file system
storage layer here
we have hdfs
and csv files were used to store that up
that type of data
excuse me
we
looked into three different types of
data to be linked in this system one was
uh electronic health record or claims
which are structured data waveform data
which is physiological parameters uh
that was captured
uh during the hospital stays like heart
rate blood pressure usually high
frequency
and also image data like echocardiogram
or mris
and then on the computational layer of
that system
we used
spark mapreduce for in-memory
computation
but to get the data from the hadoop file
system within the spark
in memory system we use
different database abstraction layers
for different types of data
like hbase for
no sql data
high for
sql type of query within hadoop system
and hippie for image processing
and on top of all of those we had a
service layer that was deployed within
kubernetes cluster
and
we deployed jupiter notebook environment
within quantities cluster but that could
be
extended with patient viewers dashboards
and guise within the same environment
uh so
researchers would only interface with
the jupiter notebook environment and
they can pull the data
and do advanced analytics or computation
from all the layers down and and without
having to
think about uh
much about infrastructure management or
setting up the data into the hpc system
so that research prototype project
actually became a campus-wide
uh initiative at purdue university
we hosted multiple large ehr and
insurance claims data into that
environment
and there were like around 100 people
including faculties and students who are
using their system
it had around 300 terabyte uh data
storage
and around um 70 million patient data
from different sources across the
country and most important of those was
the sarner hill facts which was um the
ehr data from all of signers hospitals
across the country for around 20 years
of that
and we used multiple research
publications um
with this data set and some of them are
still ongoing
the next area i wanted to talk about um
is not about the informatic system which
is on the
ai or causal inference side
so as i said uh one of the motivators
for me was
uh how do we develop a
prediction model that would explain
uh the reasoning about the predictions
for the algorithm
for safety uh and risk benefit analysis
as well as
for better understanding of the
underlying
uh clinical or biological process
so
uh to in in that area
we were
um looking into one particular framework
called structure causal model which is a
graphical model and this is a relatively
new um
um
theoretical development that's that's
been pioneered by
judah pearl from ucla
and the idea is that
all the variables within a problem
domain
needs to be represented in a causal
diagram
and
the causal diagram will dictate
how
what variables are needs to be adjusted
for confounders
and that can be used for a virtual
randomized control trials so that we
know exactly which variables
we want to intervene
and identify and remove identify the
bias and also adjust for or remove those
biases
so the biggest challenge of that uh
project or that
uh
framework is actually how do we come up
with the causal diagram in the first
place
and this is an open problem in this area
and the other traditional approaches
of causal inference which is
a propensity score based model
also look into the same potential
outcome framework
but they don't use causal graph
rather they use propensity score
to identify what to adjust for and what
not to adjust for
but the strength of this uh graphical
model is that you explicitly define
what all of your assumptions are
and then it becomes easy to
uh compare objective evolution of your
methods versus
uh one other the other methods but the
challenge here is again
uh the
how do we come up with uh the causal
graph
is is an open problem
so we have been uh working on one
project
uh
that
to reproduce randomized control trial
result from observational data
so this particular study was motivated
by
uh some
landmark studies
the first one uh so
there was a research question about
whether hormone therapy
has an uh impact of chronic heart
disease
um
in a very large randomized control trial
this randomized control trial was one of
the largest in in the history of
randomized control trial
and
this was initiated by women health
initiative
and they found that
um
the
benefit that there is a there is a risk
of hormone therapy uh using uh for for
chronic heart disease using is using
that trial
but observational study found that this
is actually beneficial
and then hernan and al used propensity
score based matching
and showed that this actually aligns
with
uh the randomized controlled trials
which is this is still harmful
so the question is why there is a
mismatch between rcd and observation
data so hernan actually established uh
this
uh research method one of the landmark
studies
uh he he showed how this can be done
with observational data so we attempted
to reproduce this result using the
graphical causal model
but as you can see on the right hand
side of this figure
um the study of the the randomized
control trial study
and the observational study
were significantly different in terms of
length of study
uh follow-up period
and some other characteristics of the
data
so how do we characterize all of these
mathematically similar to randomized
control trial and
look into the same
measures for outcome for objective
objective comparison
so we are still actually working on this
project uh and right now
what we have done is we mapped
each of these studies in terms of the
population characteristics
and uh treatment allocations or
interventions
and the actual query
uh
with the graphical causal model
and
now we need to look into the actual data
uh we are working on
identifying
completing the data use agreement
to get the raw data
and reproduce the results so this is a
theoretical word that we are ongoing and
the eventual goal is again
how do we use observational data to
reproduce
uh clinical trial quality evidence from
um from other file data
uh the other area in the causal
inference uh other other topic that in
the causal inference area that we are
working on is
uh how do we come up with the causal
graph in the first place
so this is an ongoing work as well and
the idea here is that
we will use different structured
learning algorithm
and physician input or domain knowledge
expertise
as well as literature
data that is published in high quality
journals
and then iteratively develop the causal
graph and provide
mathematical validation and experimental
uh result of the graphical model
to find the confidence in the graph that
we developed and this is a an an open
problem and this is one of the main
reason
that uh this graphical model has not
been adapted for more clinical research
because developing the graphing is
pretty difficult in the first place
so um
the idea of this framework of different
sources of knowledge embedded embedding
into the causal graph
actually comes from the hierarchy of
hierarchy of knowledge in medicine so as
as we know that
systematic reviews or randomized control
trials
have higher
quality of evidence compared to
observational data so we wanted to use
that hierarchy
uh to develop a
causal graph generator engine
that would automatically
incorporate
all these different sources of knowledge
into a causal graph
with
inputs from the experts
so right now we are working on this
framework this is an ongoing work that
we are
working on a publication right now and a
proposal is
under development for this work as well
so again the idea is we are looking at
three different sources expert knowledge
uh data knowledge from uh data which is
in the form of a structured learning
algorithm
and also the third one is the peer
review literature so we are
incorporating all these different
sources of knowledge for a sim uh
specific query
and generate the causal graph
systematically
and then evaluate that with with the
some simulation models
so that
part was pretty much about
my research activities
and on the other hat that i
wear
as the co-director of informatics
at oak tree i'll talk a little bit about
that as well
so
at oak tree
informatics i think that might be of
interest to
and and you all often all of you know
about this informatics program much more
than i do because i've been here only
for a few months
but at auction informatics we care about
uh publications and research grants and
community partnerships
industry engagement and investigator
satisfaction
uh for all of our informative work so we
want to support the community for
faculties and students
to
have better matrix in terms of these
these
variables
so this is um
what i am working on right now
uh this already exists to many extent
but i'm working with uh dr shannon
mcwinney to come up with a
uh cohesive strategy for
research data warehouse uh that usually
supports our research activities at ohsu
so at the bottom layer uh we have
supporting communities
uh that is the research community that
we support but we also want to support
startup and innovation um for technology
transfer those activities workforce and
training and computational approaches
that different faculties work across the
campus
and we are trying to make that
rdw or research data warehouse
management in in a way so that we get
input from different consortiums that we
are part of like old chain
n3c odc
uh of course which uses a big
development partners in terms of a big
database and irb data that are
b data that we
uh
maintain
sd which uh social determinants of
health for different communities that we
partner with knight cancer institute is
one of the
largest community that we work with
and also develop partnerships across the
region and across technological uh
companies
so
to achieve that
the big idea is that
data
ehr social determinants of health
imaging variables that would be at the
heart of
uh what we do at the informatics program
and the technological solutions that
that is the informatics systems
to
maintain the data in a way so that it
would support privacy
standardization interoperability
we want to develop that in a way so that
that
it becomes a vehicle for partnership and
innovation as well
and the other side of that
value generation from this data comes
from the application of different
methods
which we need to partner with
that we
biostatistics demise and other faculties
across the campus
so that this wheel of innovation can
actually speed up
the commercialization grants
publications those mattresses
and finally for oaktree because we are a
clinical and transnational research
institute funded by nih
our eventual goal is to
show the translational impact which we
can
see in terms of the clinical trials
or health matrix improvement in the
community or number of pregnant trials
or outcomes of pragmatic trials
uh for oaktree uh we also have other in
other programs like biostatistics
evolution navigator community
and we are trying to
build the synergies with those other
programs for better investigator support
uh we already do all of those things i'm
not
saying we don't do any of those
uh so i'm just trying to work with dr
sharon mcmaney for better cohesion with
those
other groups for better investigator
support
a quick summary of what we have in the
rdw data so we have around 4 million
patients from ohsu
since around i think
2005 or 2004
because that's where we have a
better ehr system implemented
and mostly we have electronic health
records but we are looking into other
partners to look into other types of
data and bring into rdw so that is not
in place yet but that's the strategic
plan that we are developing
and here is another view of the rdw
dataset that is increasing as
patients we have more patients over the
years so right now this we have almost 4
million patients
in the rdw data
so i'll stop here but before i do i want
to thank my collaborator anthograma he's
a professor of computer science so he
was my primary collaborator on the
informatics system
and professor elias berenbaum he was my
primary collaborator on the kaza
inference site
uh and is a professor of computer
science at columbia university now
and uh another uh student that i want to
mention his name is ritimal
he's a graduate student that helped in
many of those works that i have done
and many others collaborators that i
don't have the space or time to talk
about
uh today so i'll stop here and get it
back to build if you have any questions
i'm happy to answer and thanks for
listening to my talk
great thank you um are there any
questions out there
um if not i'll actually um it's it might
be more of a comment than a question um
um
the the when the women's health
initiative was published it was a big
deal around this campus because there
were many fervent views
and and i think as most people in the
audience know um
d mice stands for department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology
and the clinical epidemiology part of
the
department has been involved in
systematic reviews on many topics
related to women's health including um
hormone replacement therapy
one of the um
um
one of the explanations
so so the the people who were on the um
less favorable side of hormone
replacement therapy
um
argued that one of the problems with the
observational studies is a um
bias a socioeconomic bias and that
before the women's health initiative
study was published there was a um
women of higher socioeconomic status who
were
healthier
you know had higher incomes and better
health care and all that and um
and the and so they
that kind of
it was in fact someone um a former
faculty she's actually retired now linda
humphries some of you may remember her
um actually published an analysis
looking at that and found indeed that
that was a big confounder
with the observational data
um on the other hand um there are some
faculty
people like jeff jensen in the
department of obstetrics and gynecology
who actually argue that the
the formulations given in the women in
the women's health initiative studies
were um
not not the optimal ones um there was
this kind of time concern which i think
you're getting at in this slide um
how does that how do those things kind
of play into the data set that you're
using
and um how will it help you um
you know uncover or how might we uncover
um the truth going forward
so so the idea of this exercise is to
show that all of the comments that you
mentioned
can be represented represented
mathematically into this graphical model
and then we can
do a
mathematical query which can be
implemented in a computer system or ai
engine and can be answered automatically
so the biggest puzzle here is how do we
embed all this information which is in
your in this particular example may be
represented as selection bias for as a
social social economic factor for the
observational study and we can represent
that intercausal graph and then we have
to adjust for that in into this uh
causal query
based on the graphical structure
so if there is a confounding pathway
versus a
collider or
other other pathways then this needs to
be adjusted but if it is for as a
mediator then we don't need to adjust
for so that
uh should be derived by the causal
structure and often cases that is not
discussed in traditional observation
studies
so
i agree with all of those comments and
the part of the
research question that we are trying to
answer here is that hey this is how we
represented all of these
concerns in a graph-based method and
this is how you can adjust
a more objective way and you can be
transparent and explainable
provide this this answer like why we are
getting what type of results
okay and i see that um changda had a
question i think on the same topic i
think you
um
mostly um answered that
um
any other um
questions from
oh yeah thank you for answering my
question now so uh my understanding is
that on the uh observational data for uh
from raw stain
that data that analysis was like uh
univariate they only analyzed
they did not consider any confounders
and on the the third column that was uh
considering other confounding content
did those uh adjust for those
confounders but it was not in a very
systematic way
and then hernan at all actually showed
that use using propensity score you can
better identify those confounders and
identify what are the variables to
adjust for
okay thank you
any other
hi um hi deeb this is arvin
great presentation today that was very
illuminating thank you thank you um
i was hoping you could go back to it
might have been slide 20 the one with
a number of uh stakeholders
and
um it has that that's
that wheel
yeah i was hoping maybe you could kind
of
elaborate a little bit more about
um
let's see if we can get there
yep
yeah that one
you know just kind of
talk about
um
i know i know
some of it you've already covered but
talk a little bit more about
how the technologies there towards the
center
might
um perhaps there's been identified texts
at some of these other institutions that
you name their osu pnnl
um
how the how those are kind of
interrelated or if there's any specific
examples and how that kind of generates
out if you don't mind
yeah of course this is a very good
question so
um
i will give one example first which is
more concrete and then um other examples
which is a little bit open-ended
so the first one uh let's see we want to
integrate
uh different types of data ehr with
um
uh
electronic sorry uh wearable devices or
some other sdh data like death from the
oregon health authority or something
else
so if this data is already identified
from each of these sources
how can you still do
uh
record linkage or if it is not
de-identified
uh how can uh you still keep the privacy
preserved record linkage so there is a
company uh called databand
and they actually commercialized uh this
idea about
preserving record linkage using
some hash techniques uh from each of
these hipaa
phi identifiers
and that is being used for some of those
health information exchanges across the
country
so as an idea we can
partner with that event
but if there is any new techniques
developed in this area of privacy
preserving record linkage
that can be an opportunity to partner
with that company for licensing and
commercialization purpose
but that is just an example just it
doesn't has to be that right example
uh beyond that uh we know that
microsoft amazon
and oracle actually bought sarnar
recently as you know
which is one of the largest ehr vendor
in the country and all of these tech
companies are trying to get into
the healthcare side
and
part of that is
providing that cloud solution where you
can integrate and develop a platform
with all these
features that we talked about at the
beginning
which is
this one
and each of these areas
if we have some innovative ideas
from our faculties and students we can
work
potentially with these companies
to
develop some technology transfer
or we can support individual faculties
develop their own startup companies as
well
right
so if it makes sense to you
yeah absolutely that's that's terrific i
love the vision thank you
thank you
great any other
questions
comments
okay well we can uh we can give people a
little bit of their um their day back i
want to um thank um adi
for presenting and i i hope that um
faculty and students um who have been
listening in can um
um you know if they have anything that
overlaps with adev's interests
be in touch with them
and of course through oaktree there's a
lot of potential data for people uh to
use in their
resource in their research so thank you
adib and um
we'll see you all at the conference next
week
thank you so much thanks everyone for
giving your time today thank you